nvidia is in the process of letting you
share games over the internet as a part
of its upcoming GeForce experience
update much like the ps4 share play
feature in videos game stream co-op
feature will attempt to simulate a local
multiplayer experience over the Internet
basically the program will let someone
virtually sit next to you on the
internet so they can take over the
controls to either give the game ago or
helped you through a tricky spot game
stream cults will also enable another
person to play alongside you in
supported multi controller games like
trine 3 gauntlet FIFA 15 and Mortal
Kombat complete if you want to be the
one sharing you'll need at least an
NVIDIA GTX 650 card
this feature is learning as part of the
upcoming share update the GeForce
experience which will launch in beta
form other features arriving with the
update include a new game overlay
improved broadcasting tools and the
ability to retro actively record the 20
most recent minutes of footage does this
face fast your interest or not be sure
leave me your thoughts and feelings and
stay tuned to games but for everything
that matters in gaming